well it's already shaping up to be a
glorious weekend of sunshine but the hot
weather brings with it some risks the UK
Health security agency has put an Amber
health warning in place for the east and
south of England and the Midlands right
through until Monday morning as
temperatures are expected to hit 30
degrees meaning some parts of the
country could be hotter than Ibiza now
in practice what it means is that the
high temperatures could be dangerous
they could actually put some pressure on
the NHS so the advice is fairly simple
and common sense it's things like check
on Friends relatives and neighbors
particularly if they're elderly if you
are out in the sunshine wear sunscreen
drink plenty of water avoid alcohol or
at least avoid drinking too much and
familiarize yourself with the symptoms
of heat exhaustion and heat stroke
nobody is saying you shouldn't go out
and enjoy the Glorious sunshine it's
just a question of doing it responsibly